the original Amazing Stories was an
iconic show the idea that there was a
Spielberg bit of magic every week that
would be in your home was like beyond
comprehension as a kid what is it well
that's fine now what I love so much
about amazing stories is that really
opens up your imagination every week you
are in a different world is it a ghost
story is an alien story like you just
never know and that was our goal for
this show look all the episodes have
their own themes and unique stories
about what happens when the ordinary
touches the extraordinary of course not
these episodes represent every walk of
life it's really an escape into a world
of wonder and possibility these great
adventure stories they have a lot of
heart they have a message beyond the
adventure at hand I love that each
episode you can get wrapped up in an
entirely new world entirely different
story maybe all this always happened
maybe you're always meant to come back
with me I think it's so cinematic and
epic strong these are stories that don't
shy away from complex human reality
it's almost common their story is that
movie stories that are about human
connection gotta go now
it really makes your hair stand on end
[Music]
we're bringing back that same level of
magic that people got when they first
started watching amazing stories
it was so much fun to craft these
episodes to do ghost story and to do an
alien story to do a superhero story on a
time travel story and a romance we're
really excited now that everyone's
finally getting a chance to see study it
all you want answer isn't up there it's
not written in the stars we're in
control
you know it's time for you to stop
looking
[Music]
your life is waiting go out there and
get it
[Music]
it's your turn now
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you